DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE"
"THE FIVE."
TULSI GABBARD AND HILLARY.
TULSI IS WINNING.
>> PEOPLE WARNED ME THAT MY
ENDORSEMENT OF BERNIE SANDERS
WOULD BE THE END OF MY
"POLITICAL CAREER."
IF THEY CAN FALSELY CALL ME A
TRAITOR, THEY CAN DO IT TO
ANYONE.
IF YOU STAND UP TO HILLARY, THEY
WILL DISCREDIT YOU.
BUT HERE IS THE TRUTH.
THEY WILL NOT INTIMIDATE US.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE A MESSAGE
FROM THE FUTURE PURGES LIKE A
HAWAIIAN SARAH CONNOR.
EVEN TRUMP WEIGHED IN.
>> President Trump:
HILLARY CLINTON.
IF YOU'VE HEARD OF HER, SHE'S
THE ONE THAT IS ACCUSING ANYONE
OF BEING A RUSSIAN AGENT.
TULSI, I DON'T KNOW TULSI, BUT
SHE'S NOT A RUSSIAN AGENT.
I DON'T KNOW JOEL STEIN.
I KNOW SHE LIKES ENVIRONMENTS.
THE ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENT.
I DON'T THINK SHE LIKES
RUSSIANS.
I THINK THAT TULSI GABBARD
PROBABLY GOT HELPED A LOT.
>> Greg: MEANWHILE, ON MSNBC
PANEL MOCKED TULSI FOR NOT
DENYING THAT SHE WAS A RUSSIAN
ACID.
>> ONE THING THAT WAS
INTERESTING ABOUT
TULSI GABBARD'S RESPONSE, SHE
SAID THAT SHE WASN'T GOING TO
RUN.
SHE NEVER DENIED BEING A RUSSIAN
ACID.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT WAS ONE THING THAT WAS
MISSING FROM HER RESPONSE.
IT WAS NOT THERE.
>> Greg: WHAT A GOOGLE FAST.
WHAT A SET OF.
SPEAKING OF WHICH, HERE'S JOY.
>> SHE HASN'T DENIED IT.
SHE HASN'T SAID ANYTHING IN HER
TWEETS.
HOW DARE YOU.
SHE DIDN'T SAY THAT.
SHE'S JUST GOING AFTER HILLARY.
I JUST THINK THAT SHE COULD BE A
USEFUL IDIOT THE WAY TRUMP IS A
USEFUL IDIOT.
THEY SAY, OH, LOOK, A USEFUL
IDIOT.
LET'S PLAY THIS.
>> Greg: JOY CALLING SOMEONE
IN A DEED.
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO REMINDS
YOU OF THE PAST, IT'S A CLINTON.
THEIR FAVORITE SMEAR, RUSSIAN
ASSETS.
THEY SAID TRUMP WAS ONE.
AND NOW, THEY ARE SAYING THAT IT
IS A YOUNG VETERAN WHO SERVED
HER COUNTRY WHILE REJECTING
CONVENTIONAL IDEOLOGY.
THERE'S LOTS TO DISAGREE WITH ON
TULSI, BUT AT LEAST YOU KNOW
SHE'S REAL, WHICH IS WHY THE
DEMS FEAR HER.
THEY CAN'T FIGURE HER OUT.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY SO MANY
REPUBLICANS LIKE HER.
SHE ISN'T MANUFACTURED TO PLEASE
THE BOSS AT MSNBC.
BUT HILLARY IS.
HER COMMENTARY KEEPS REMINDING
YOU OF WHY TRUMP WON.
THINK ABOUT IT.
SHE SAYS THAT A SO-CALLED
RUSSIAN ASSET WOULD SPLIT THE
DEMOCRATIC VOTE IF SHE WENT
ROGUE.
DESPITE RED HILLARY CLAIMS,
TULSI IS NO JOEL STEIN.
SHE IS NOT TO THE LEFT OF THE
DEMS, BUT TO THE RIGHT OF THE
DEMS.
SHE MAKES IT CLEAR WHO THE
REPUBLICAN ASSET IS.
ARE WE SURE THAT SHE IS NOT ON
TRUMP'S PAYROLL?
I HAVE A THEORY.
I HAVEN'T NAMED IT YET, BUT I
CALL IT SMEAR BY EXTERNAL
PREFERENCE.
THAT MEANS THAT YOU CAN BE IN A
VERY POPULAR PUNK BAND, BUT
AMONG YOUR FANS ARE SKINHEADS.
IF SOMEONE COULD SAY, OH, YOU
ARE A SKIN HAD.
SOME
OF THEM ARE RUSSIAN.
SOME OF THEM ARE CANADIAN.
SHE CAN'T HELP, LIKEWISE, WE
CAN'T HELP WHO ARE FANS ARE.
SO, IF CANADIANS LIKE YOU, ARE
YOU A CANADIAN ASSET?
DO YOU SEE MY POINT?
>> YES.
I'M NOT A CANADIAN ACID.
I PUBLICLY REBUFF JUSTIN BIEBER
AT ANY OPPORTUNITY.
YOU MENTIONED THE WORD BITTER.
I WROTE DOWN, BITTERNESS IS
HILLARY CLINTON'S FAVORITE COLOR
OF LIPSTICK.
ALL OF HER FAILURES, SHE CAN'T
TAKE OWNERSHIP OF THEM.
TO HER FANS, AND THERE ARE STILL
A FEW, SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO BEAT TRUMP, BUT IN THAT PLUS
PODCAST THAT SHE DID, OF COURSE,
SHE HAS TO GO AFTER FOX NEWS.
SHE LONGS FOR THE DAY WHERE
THERE WERE JUST THREE TELEVISION
NETWORKS AND A FEW NEWSPAPERS,
AND SHE ACTUALLY HAD THE
AUDACITY TO SAY IT WAS A MUCH
MORE CONTROLLABLE ENVIRONMENT.
SO, IT'S A LOT HARDER FOR
AMERICANS TO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE.
THAT'S HOW SHE VIEWS THE WORLD,
THAT SHE IS OUT THERE TO --
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THEY BELIEVE AND THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IN YOU.
>> Greg: E.
DON'T YOU AGREE THAT IF TULSI
RAN, WANTED IT HURTS TRUMP MORE
THAN IT WOULD HURT THE DEMS?
IN MY WRONG?
I SENSE THAT.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT ON THE
LEFT, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SOME ON THE LEFT HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH TULSI GABBARD IS THAT SHE
IS NOT ANTIWAR PURCHASE KIND OF
A HAWK, BUT SHE WOULD USE DRONES
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF LIBERALS WHO
DON'T WANT THAT AT ALL EITHER.
LIBERTARIANS, I'M NOT SURE THEY
ARE SO MUCH FOR THAT AS WELL.
1.4 MILLION PEOPLE VOTED FOR
JOEL STEIN IN THE ELECTION.
OUT OF 330 ODD MILLION PEOPLE,
THAT'S NOT THAT MANY.
BUT IF YOU WERE ONE OF THEM,
WOULD YOU BE MOTIVATED TO RETURN
TO THE DEMOCRATIC POLL?
PROBABLY NOT.
I DON'T NECESSARILY, I DON'T
THINK THAT MEANS THAT SHE'S
GOING TO ALL OF THE SITE
GOING TO ALL OF THE SUDE
GOING TO ALL OF THE SUDDEN TURN
TO REPUBLICAN VOTERS.
SHE GOT A TON OF FREE PUBLICITY.
AND FOR WHAT?
WHAT HAS IT ACCOMPLISHED FOR
HILLARY CLINTON?
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ANYTHING.
>> Greg: MAY BE MORE BOOK
SALES, BECAUSE SHE NEEDS THE
MONEY, YOU KNOW.
ONE OF MY SMARTEST FRIENDS,
WALTER, IS 100% POSITIVE THAT
SHE'S ENTERING THE RACE.
ONE OF MY OTHER SMART FRIENDS,
SCOTT, SAYS THAT THERE IS NO WA
WAY.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
DO THINK THIS IS ALL BECAUSE
SHE'S COMING BACK?
>> Jesse: NO, I DON'T THINK
THAT SHE'S GOING TO ENTER THE
RACE.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE HER.
THEY DON'T LIKE HER ON THE
RIGHT, THEY DON'T LIKE HER IN
THE MIDDLE, AND NOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT DON'T LIKE
HER.
SHE'S A FEMINIST, GREG.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
THIS WOMAN WENT OVERSEAS TO LAY
HER LIFE DOWN FOR HER COUNTRY
AND HILLARY IS SMEARING HER AS A
RUSSIAN.
SHE PROBABLY ACTUALLY HAD SNIPER
FIRE OVER HER HEAD.
HILLARY IS SO TOUGH ON RUSSIA.
I MEAN COME A FEW YEARS AGO, SHE
WAS GIGGLING, LAUGHING IT UP.
SHE'S SO TOUGH?
A COUPLE YEARS AGO, SHE CALLED
ASSAD A REFORMER.
A REFORMER.
NANCY PELOSI AND A BUNCH OF
DEMOCRATS WENT OVER TO SYRIA.
SHE SHOOK HANDS WITH A SAUD.
NOW THEY HAVE TO KILL HIM TO BE
TOUGH?
AND IF YOU DON'T WANT TO KILL
HIM, YOU ARE A RUSSIAN ACID?
IT'S SO CRAZY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NEVER BEEN
TOUGH
ON RUSSIA.
THEY WERE AGAINST EVERYTHING
RONALD REAGAN WAS DOING TO
DEFEAT THE SOVIET UNION.
ROMNEY GOT MOCKED FOR SAYING --
NOW, THEY SAY, OH, IF YOU ARE
NOT AGAINST RUSSIA.
PROXY WARS.
BUT THEY HACK A DEMOCRAT'S
COMPUTER, AND ALL OF THE SUDDEN,
WE ARE IN WORLD WAR III?
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JUAN.
IS SHE A RUSSIAN AGENT?
BEFORE I DON'T KNOW.
>> Greg: ALL, JUAN.
ARE YOU A RUSSIAN AGENT, JUAN?
>> Juan: COULD BE.
SHE HAS NO POLITICAL FUTURE.
SHE IS NOT RUNNING.
I THINK THAT WHAT YOU HAVE HERE
IS THAT SHE IS FREE TO SPEAK HER
MIND, AND SHE DOES NOT WANT A
REPEAT OF WHAT HAPPENED TO A
THIRD-PARTY CANDIDATE IN 2016.
BECAUSE REMEMBER, JOEL STEIN GOT
1% IN MICHIGAN, WISCONSIN,
PENNSYLVANIA, THAT EXCEEDED THE
MARGIN OF TRUMP'S VICTORY.
WE ARE TALKING A BIG JUMP IN
TERMS OF ELECTORAL VOTES.
LET ME JUST SAY, AND REMEMBER,
JOEL
JIEL
JILL STEIN.
SHE GETS LIKE 2% IN THE POLLS
RIGHT NOW, BUT GUESS WHAT, SHE'S
ALL OVER.
SHE GETS LOTS OF ATTENTION.
SHE GETS LOTS OF ATTENTION FROM
FAR RIGHT CONSPIRACY PEOPLE.
THEY LOVE HER.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE
ARE SAYING, HEY.
WAIT A SECOND.
ARE THERE RUSSIANS TRYING TO
EXPLOIT TULSI GABBARD CUSTOMER
SHE DOESN'T NEED TO BE A RUSSIAN
ACID.
SHE CAN BE SOMEONE WHO IS
EXPLOITED TO DIMINISH DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: WHICH IS MY POINT.
IF YOU CAN'T CONTROL AN EXTERNAL
PREFERENCE.
IF SOMEONE IS A FAN OF YOUR
BAND, YOU CAN'T SAY NO.
>> Juan: NO, BUT THIS IS
POLITICS.
WHEN YOU SEE RIGHT WING PEOPLE
REPORTING TULSI GABBARD, THEY
HAVE A REASON.
>> Greg: NO, ACTUALLY RIGHT
WING PEOPLE SUPPORTING
TULSI GABBARD HURTS THEM,
BECAUSE THEY WON'T VOTE FOR
TRUMP.
>> Juan: NO, SHE IS STILL
BEING USED BY THE RIGHT.